hello and welcome to this video playing
Little Master here with white do we get
Kalashnikov okay hmm I wonder b6 is a
little bit honey it's at the normal
water no I don't know does it make sense
to go here anyway let's get going just
normal moves cannot be that terrible him
yeah this is actually not that bad
putting on a 3-2 have 92 available in
case of 94 so it's 94 move here maybe
what do I play f3 maybe I'm episode I'm
not quite sure f3 looks a little bit
stodgy night situ mi peanut in five ok
I'm going f3 it's been a while since I
looked at this look at this line for
black looks looks fairly normal
disposition maybe he has some 94 idea ok
just Queen d2 maybe
yeah one knows it now all night
institute now that you cannot play
Knight a5 that just makes some sense
actually uh-huh
okay mind some kind of ending here he
kind of has to me Queen a5 we should be
six I think blunders a full/queen more
or less he has got a five though the
matter that is a move there's an
interesting move maybe I it's not a big
deal but in five I did not really
appreciate beforehand this is the this
is what he has to think about yet the
mode and there's no other explanation
okay so if I take it I can take before
and then play 95 shouldn't be bad
[Music]
it's a very long thought that really
since you use huge decision decision
while so it goes a fine yeah I kind of
have to go 95 I don't believe you're
threatening to check on c4 it's just
like just what it is so
I probably have to do it the animatic
with the sea pond is going to invade
with the rook which isn't the end of the
world admittedly i went--both TM I think
this is better anyway if i get if i can
take B form the porn be form would be
quite a week if it takes okay so if i
take this now and play b3 isn't he
losing this pawn he might have from
dynamic ideas of course but yea wat just
immediately i just got be five yeah they
have to do this anyway in case of b5 so
okay I'm pukey wants to go 986 hmm and
that I should have anticipated really
should have but ok it's what it is still
not a bad position
Oh came before and before we should be
sick so I have to go here prevent them
[Music]
okay ff4 it's not a big deal so let's
see that I can't get those pawns those
palms forward be 45
sorry yeah I don't know black doesn't
really have all that much active plane
[Music]
looks awkward I get in before and then
c5 is just around the corner
c5 cakes Bishop a six Wow nice he wants
to I don't know what he wants to do so
c5 takes it Bishop takes a six ctx
before it's probably coming here so i
probably need need to get out of this to
prepare c5
well c5 is pretty awkward that's not
going to end well I don't think so this
bone roller together with the bishop
here it's pretty pretty strong unless he
has a tactic or something no I don't
don't see it my cakes i can click with
the rook and currently this just hanging
him before bishop 86 yahoo jakes b 5 is
a simpler smooth just take everything so
this night time learning doesn't have
many squares
[Music]
yeah just keep keep everything hand and
push through em so d 6 or justice
there's no reason not to cover it does
he have that one check I'll just cover
the background check check black for
fits on time oh don't make me all fuzzy
at the end okay so um well interesting
really interesting not yet face this
opening all that much no he's playing
come on it's all nice and good to
analyze with the opponent but not in a
video that it's just completely erratic
yo yo you cannot kind of do it so yeah I
don't know if create fire does all that
great I felt like this could be
something after f3 because I mean I
cannot just grab the pawn because of
this d5 shot and I felt after 94 I
probably have to yeah play something
slow yeah like this is what the engine
suggests that seems ok for black and
this I think is quite nice because for
me because 95 now is
on the picture I was always concerned if
I played this that he has Knight a5 this
kind of thing and this is in fact looks
a little bit awkward so now I can do
that this is this and queen bee three
and now I felt normal would be to take
and play this position after which i
think the engines assessment of 0.4 0.5
looks kind of normal what white should
be a bit better because of his face but
black seems very solid him you played
this however and now here we get into
the structure yeah the computer wants to
do this I wasn't sure takes takes takes
I'm taking this though so it might be
that this is often not this is actually
the point that's good you cannot take
because this is blundering a full rook
and then this is strong if you cannot
get to the second and this is strong but
this is also not bad Bishop t2 there was
something I didn't like like be five but
the engine just says this is also good
for me which is true Matt didn't see
that I felt like I can I can play it
slowly here this is this is too too slow
this position gets to be very good for
white preparing before why now this is
just pretty bad what this and want to do
oh that's a nice shot that's a nice one
I would have shocked me really this
thing
okay is good for wide right at the end
24 yeah well this is this is a very
tricky position with no time on the
clock I would actually assume that if
you have time you should win this and
the engine is getting higher and higher
but this upon that would have been
tricky I don't know that would if we
found that move for example doesn't feel
like here compte 6 this is an important
trick and it would have been would have
been tricky now this was relatively easy
now you doing all this hectic moves then
check but okay why this up a million
billionaire material ok guys thanks for
watching